so that's interesting because I think a
lot of people that are signed are going
to feel like they're that's where their
work stops in terms of them having a
search so can you dispel that myth so
folks are absolutely fine by it one of
the bigger agencies they feel like okay
now I've arrived but really not the
interesting thing is that most writers
who get wrapped right even in the bigger
on the the kind of bigger landscape with
a bigger agency CAW UTA ICM if they
truly stop and ask their agent and
manager or their agent so are you going
to get me a job most of them are going
to tell them getting you your first job
is not my responsibility that is the
truth of the matter so writers have to
continue to network to get themselves
out there so for example I had a writer
who was one day UCLA contest on both the
feature or the TV original TV pilot and
spec front as you do got a manager
through that then went on and got into
two fellowships in one year got a
manager and an agent ultimately got her
job through her fellowship but her
management was instrumental and
introducing her to her showrunner
who then paid for her out-of-pocket
which is pretty non-standard when it
comes to the writing programs that are
supposed to subsidized some of these
staff writer roles so I find that
writers when writers get repped
especially with a manager but it's also
true with an agent
there's always ongoing work whether it's
networking whether it's doing showrunner
meetings not getting the job and then
getting the you know the the all the
gift that is the freelance the freelance
script on the TV season so there's a lot
of work to be done by the writer it's
rarely just sit on your hands I have a
writer who was in a showrunner meeting
today know how it went yet who is always
out there who's always networking who is
it every event who is on board with the
WGA who is on the board with the pga who
is just always out there working for
himself and getting himself out there
yes his agents at WME are carrying part
of the load but he is doing a fair share
of the work now the important thing to
remember is that your agents and your
managers they're collecting 10% getting
a writer his first job is math 10% of
the work it's going to take a lot more
than that because of that writers have
to always be vigilant about getting out
there and working their contacts and
communicating with their people and
getting to know show runners and doing
everything that they can if not to get
the job than to inspire their reps to
work even harder for them okay so now
I'm rep now what where does the real
work begins now now the pressures on now
the real pressure is on because
ultimately you got reps on the scripts
you got rep on contest win or a
fellowship placement now it's about
continuing to impress your rep to no
longer about the one script that will
get you that one person's attention now
it's about staying front of mind for
your rep so it's continuing to generate
work not taking too much time between
script but making sure the scripts are
up to standard it's about continuing to
network calling in to your agents office
and saying I just met with yada-yada can
you send them the script it's about you
know have a writer who just got signed
got two months ago and she is constantly
she's a master networker she is
constantly out there meeting with people
and calling her manager and saying I
just met with this person who wants me
to work on that idea please please pick
it up and run with it so it's working
even harder working with a greater
sensitivity to your manager your agent
sensibilities what they will or won't
get out there it's about showing them
your hunger not not in words but in
actions it's about managing your
communication it's about understanding
that until you've begun to work they're
working for you for free so you better
be nice about it it's really not the
time to pop up you're out of your chest
you know but really respecting the
relationship and respecting what they
are doing for you oftentimes for free
for a long period of time while
continuing to impress them you want them
to continue to bet on you and for that
you have to hit the bull's eye every
time
so the writing has to be that much
stronger you have to deliver you have to
be great in meetings they have to get
calls from their friends the executive
saying April was just in here oh my god
I loved her she is so great I want to
develop something with her keep me in
mind for her next script you have to
impress you have to impress at every
turn and you know oftentimes most
writers by the time they get picked up
for representation have the capacity to
do that because they've interfaced with
enough writers they've met the industry
they've worked on their personal story
they want to be collaborative they want
that push and they understand that this
is a hard industry to crack but once you
do it's it's really great it's really
fun and so they're willing to put in the
work but the work only gets more
demanding
I don't know that harder is the right
work word but more and more demanding as
you go along to get an agent you get a
manager as you meet executives as you're
impressed executives as you build your
fan base that wants to read the next
thing and the next thing you always have
to get better you have to get stronger